hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to jumped over now this
isn't your average game of jump rope I
know you've got scores and book shelves
full of jump rope style simulator games
on your gaming bookshelf
no this one's different for it is deadly
and bloody and if you don't jump correct
I can't why can't I jump I was pushing
the button and then I died but that's
this game it's the most intense you
could go gin shove all those games you
got on your shelf into the trash bin cuz
it's not the same as best I can again
with the not letting me jump I'm dead
that's a bloody cactus it doesn't want
to jump correctly all the time Oh Frick
oh my god that is that is a rough way to
go okay let's see if I can change
characters Oh No is that the only
character I have okay cool
he oh I can't jump there we go oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
there's no waiting in jump doper there's
no way I can win one cuz it oh my god it
doesn't let you jump in - oh it doesn't
let you jump until you're already when
it's perfectly softly down on the oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh yeah sword it
you go I think I got it
the winning stratagem oh my god well the
best oh my god
humming humming let's get faster it's
getting faster or is it I can't tell who
it is getting faster oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god car unlocked car my
car is unlocked these guys liked my joke
you like my funny jokes my jokes are
funny guys
oh that's a good car oh that's not a
good car the car died really quickly
yeah okay good Billy a little too girthy
for this I don't like using the term
girthy for this because I don't want to
imagine anything that I don't want
getting sliced apart and sliced apart in
here oh my but my delicious car but oh
yeah that's the way you want to stand oh
god no I'm gonna make it I'm gonna make
it I'm gonna get the high score oh I've
been visited nice and easy
well I could yeah I could use a little
off the top I don't need all that I'm
gonna try to unlock at least one more
character before I fall the pieces
around here okay I'm not as nimble as I
would like how do they make this is it
like a oh god getting fast
oh why stop shaving my thank you
why women why why waffle waffle why why
waffle fries oh oh oh oh no like the
trick that I'm doing to get this is I'm
pressing as many buttons as possible
every time I need to jump that's the
only way that I can like almost
predictably get it to jump because this
is regard am Nicholas I hate you hate
you I hate you I hate you hey no stop
jiggling Oh II that's fun this is great
great great great that's why did you do
that
why why why why why is had one bad boy
now you're just gonna get yourself
killed
no yes break dance break dance baby
okay now lie flat yeah that's that's not
good go oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
[Music]
one more try if this doesn't work it's
not gonna work ever oh my god oh my god
oh yeah oh yes oh yes oh yes oh yes oh
yes I can't see it I can't see it it's
the wrong direction for this but I got
it so good yes please no God don't stop
me now I'm not dead yet
there we go i unlock the bondable and
look the bottle oh good okay that's
gonna work this is let's just do this am
I gonna spew liquid out of the top of me
once I get slist nope I don't I don't
but least I'm a smaller target
oh [ __ ] here I go again with the guano
yeah I can't see again just gotta like
it's it's when it goes this direction I
can't see anything so I gotta go buy a
pure instinct alone poo god I'm gonna
die but I'll gonna die bottles gonna die
flippin like crazy oh my god you are out
of your goddamn mind
this okay here we go
Wow okay there we are I'm not gonna make
it oh god alright fine that's enough of
that
that's my score and that's what you guys
gotta try to be so I'm gonna leave it at
that so 50 ominous blades whipping and
wrapping over in the distance there
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know how I did in the comments
down below and let me know if you can
beat my high score as well put a link in
the description so thanks again
everybody for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]